this is a production of cornell
university
i will be presenting on the work i've
done for the last three growing seasons
here at cornell working with justine van
hoovel with thomas bjorkman and anna
katherine mansfield also on my committee
the work here for my masters has
centered around using undervine cover
crops as an herbicide replacement in
cool climate riesling vineyards
so i'll go quickly over the background
why am i even bothering to look at this
in for my materials and methods i did
all my experiments at two field sites so
i'll go over over the design at both of
them
my different results and at the end of
the day what can we say about this work
so currently it is
pretty commonplace to use cover crops at
some point in the season between vine
rows but it is almost universally kept
weed free or vegetation free in the zone
directly beneath vines
this bare soil strip is maintained with
a combination or selection of herbicide
and or cultivation this is done because
growers perceive that it would be a very
negative effect on vines having
vegetation there it's not so much
support in the science literature but
it's definitely the perception and that
is why it's done
so any risk there's always a risk when
you introduce an herbicide to a system
not only are you in increasing your
chances of resistance in the weed
community but you're always offering the
opportunity for these herbicides to
leach out
or run off this is a special concern
when you're growing vineyards above
lakes like in this region
and if you're worried about
contaminating your ground water sources
and regardless of whether you're using
herbicide or cultivation bare soil is a
big risk in terms of your soil health
any kind of bear exposed soil is going
to be subject to crusting during a hard
rainfall event which leads to further
runoff you get soil structure
degradation
a decrease in organic matter and also
it's very subject to erosion anytime
soil is left bare this is a great
concern when you have vineyards planted
on hillsides which is very common not
only here in the finger lakes but
worldwide
so this is all coupled with the fact
that if you look at kind of the state of
the union of vineyard growth habits in
this region we have a lot of very
excessively vegetative growing vines for
lack of a better phrase
you can see that picture there the
shoots have not only well extended
beyond the trellising but they're
starting to grow into the next row
we have frequent rainfall throughout the
growing season here so water is rarely a
limiting factor
many vineyards are planted on what just
happened to be very deep in fertile soil
sites so though that's not a limiting
factor and we also just have selected
due to commercial and production reasons
some varieties that just have a
particularly vigorous growth habit so
all this sort of creates the perfect
trifecta of growing more like jungles
than little vineyards
this excessive vegetative growth is a
problem because it is associated with
very poor resulting grape and wine
quality shaded buds are less fruitful
a lot of the desirable aromas we want in
our wine are correlated with sunlight
exposure so when you have 15 bazillion
leaf layers blocking them you're not
going to get a lot of exposure
and those conditions are really ripe for
disease all that leaf area is going to
contribute to a higher relative humidity
and just make it harder to get into the
canopy to manage your fruit
and so
given that deleterious effect on the
vines from this excessive vegetative
growth we spend a lot of time and money
in vineyards maintaining it we'll go
through in
pretty much right from the time shoots
burst and have to remove vegetative
growth we'll take out shoots we'll leave
thin we'll drop excess clusters we'll
drive tractors throughout the entire
season to hedge off those tops of shoots
but this is all costly and takes lots of
time to manage and it's also at the end
of the day just treating the problem not
the source of the problem
so there's been successful research in
other humid climates that have this
excessive growth problem in new zealand
long island and virginia that have shown
that when you replace using herbicides
direct lander vines and instead plant a
very intentionally planted under vine
cover crop not only are you eliminating
herbicide use but you're actually
getting a positive deviating effect
however as this californian can tell you
the finger lakes is pretty cold
and we aren't as warm as these other
regions so we have sort of a different
management
practicality to work around in the
winter we mound up a lot of soil around
the graft union of vines the european
grapevines you guys are going to be
familiar with including riesling which
is what my research is done on are all
planted on rootstock so if we ever had a
really hard freeze these vines would
kill to the ground and all you're going
to be left with is your rootstock which
isn't going to produce your fruit and
you're pretty much back to square one so
by healing up this dirt all over those
graft unions you're ensuring the
survival of some scion buds which come
the spring you heal back down you can
grow up
your your riesling or your cab franc or
whatever it may be from those surviving
buds and you're not back to square one
you still have some work ahead of you
but you're not devastated also at the
end of the day crop insurance requires
growers to heal up so regardless of
whether you're going to take the chance
or not you're pretty much going to do it
so given this
need to heal up vines in the winter and
heal them back down in the spring we
have to operate on kind of a different
system vineyard floor management system
than these other regions which showed
success with looking at permanently
established perennials
that's why my objective for my master's
work was to look at annually established
undervine cover crop species as an
alternative to herbicide in finger lakes
riesling vineyards
we hypothesized that given this very
common excessive vegetative growth habit
of riesling grapevines in the region
that there will be no deleterious effect
by introducing this underlying cover
crop vegetation with the vines
we actually if anything predict that
there would be a positive outcome by
reducing this figure
so my data sort of stemmed on two sides
of looking at the question the first was
looking at different measures of
vegetative growth
right now and subsequently taking some
rough measures of vine nutrient and
water status for water i looked at
midday and pre-dawn stem water
potentials i'll talk about those later
take a quick moment because i'll mention
several times enhanced point quadrant
analysis or epqa is a way of quantifying
the canopy canopy characteristics the
number of leaves the number of clusters
those sorts of things and the light
environment within the canopy that's
what jim myers did for his phd a former
student of justine's he's now a postdoc
for us so that's building upon his work
and then a petiole were collected at
verizon
for nutrient analysis for that side of
things then
i don't just watch the vines grow all
season but i do in fact harvest the
fruit and different measures that
harvest are taken and then the
subsequent juice is analyzed brix is our
measures of sugar so the soluble solids
in the juice sugar is really important
because in fermentation sugar goes out
to alcohol
ta is short for titratable acidity this
is really important for your perception
of acid in the wine and juice ph not
only is it related to acid but really
important for microbial stability in
wines so we don't have bugs that we
don't want growing in there and tainting
your wine and yan is short for yeast
assimible nitrogen this is important
because yeast are biota a living
organism and we want them to do our
bidding of converting sugar to alcohol
so we need to provide them with enough
nutrients for them to do that when you
have low nitrogen values fermentations
can get stuck and sluggish putting off
off aromas and at the end of the day not
completing your fermentation so that's
why it's an important value to look at
and i also subjected these wines to a
sensory analysis
looking at differences perceived in wine
aroma which i'll also talk about later
so to give you an idea of the
abbreviated season we're working with in
may we get bud break this is when
grapevines are dehilled that soil is
pushed back down from the roots or from
the over the graft union this is also
when i begin to establish my underlying
cover crops
by bloom which occurs in mid-june you
can see that's the second picture at the
top there we're not pretty like the
apples but it happens nonetheless
the cover crops have emerged this is
also typically when growers will start
having to manage any kind of excess
vegetative growth they'll start going in
and shoot thinning they might adjust
cluster crop that kind of thing
this is also when i start looking at
the water potential readings
and i start tracking shoot lengths
verizon is a really critical time in our
world veraison is the fancy word we have
for when ripening really starts to
accelerate this is when sugar starts to
rapidly accumulate in the fruit acid
levels start to drop in red varieties
you get the green to red color shift
change and in the whites you do get a
color shift it goes from those bright
like hard green berries to the skin
soften and in recently it turns a nice
kind of bright yellow color
harvest
roughly happened late september to most
likely early october this is when all
the fruits taken off the vines i take
different yield components i crush the
fruit analyze the juice and the juices
then put through fermentation to be
completed wines
by november we are healing our
grapevines back up and this is sort of
would be the end date then for my
undervine cover crops because we have a
giant cultivation operation underneath
the vines at this point the vines have
pretty much gone dormant and have leaves
drop and they're preparing to hibernate
in the winter like i wish i was
as i said i do make wine from the juice
this is sort of a standard white wine
fermentation procedure
that in general was held for both of my
lots what's important to note here is
that for each treatment there are
duplicate lots of wine made
and the whole idea is since this is a
viticultural trial i'm trying to be as
hands-off as possible in the enological
process and try to allow characteristics
in the vineyard to be carried through so
i'm using a yeast that doesn't throw off
a lot of interesting aromas i uh
chopalize or add sugar to a standard
sugar level i supplement the yeast or
the yam level to make sure
these yeast are going to be able to go
and i do ferment these wines to dryness
so for the multi-dimensional sorting
analysis by wine aroma the big fancy
word for my sensory tests in short
all the duplicate lots were presented to
panelists and they were asked to sort
wines by similarity into groups if you
found a wine to be similar
to another wine you put them in the same
group if you found them to be different
you put them in different groups this
gets a lot of grouping data data that's
then run through sas and can give you a
visual representation of the differences
which i'll be showing you later so i had
two field sites that i did my research
on the first was an uh commercial
vineyard on the east side of seneca lake
um these vines were older almost 20 year
old 20 years old now
i planted on a honey oil silt loam
riesling and what i want to note here is
it's a scott henry training system
meaning that there is both an upper and
lower fruiting zone
this is important because we'll often do
this in vineyards that have sort of
excessive growth but this already has
been done at this vineyard and we were
still seeing excessive growth
um there were treatments the underlying
cover crops were originally planted in
2011 and carried through through this
year in a randomized complete block
design with four replicates per
treatment
my four treatments were as such annual
rye grass planted in the middle of may
this is a later establishing while
planted in the middle of may it doesn't
really get going and i noticed the most
biomass accumulation much later in the
season such as july august and it grows
well through october
buckwheat that beautiful white flowering
plant
has seeded in late may interesting about
buckwheat is it frost kills so that'd be
ideal for a kind of abbreviated time
frame that we're looking for
buckwheat also has a lot of notoriety
right now because work out of berkeley
and work by greg globe here has shown
that it could potentially increase
the incidence of generalist predators in
the vineyard and increase rates of
parasitism of vineyard pests there's a
lot of interest around buckwheat
natural vegetation polite word for
wheats
we allow them to grow throughout the
season whatever may be there and then
our control is the traditional
glyphosate spray
applied one to two times a year the
underlying cover crop treatments were
mowed as needed to keep them from
getting too tall into the canopy and
that ended up being one to two times a
year
my second site is the cornell orchards
at lansing in one of the riesling blocks
that i kind of inherited from ian
merwin's old work
here these fines were originally planted
in 2007 it once again is a two-tier flat
bow which is a double canopy fruiting
system and that picture that i used on
the slide about excessive vigor came
from this site so i can assure you that
there's a lot of excess vigor here
these treatments were originally
established in 2012 and carried out this
year this site's a little complicated so
i'll do my best to describe it under
vine cover crops are planted down the
entire lengths of rows each cover crop
was planted down four rows in its
entirety there is then an overlay of
irrigation at this site that allows me
to irrigate half of a given row which
half as irrigated alternates down the
rows the whole site is in total just
under one acre to put that size into
perspective
i just i initiated irrigation
when the average midday leaf stem water
potential exceeded minus eight bars this
is a rough threshold for when vine water
status tends to be inhibited inhibiting
vegetative growth so that's kind of
where that number came from in 2012 we
irrigated three times in 2013 it never
actually got that
that dry to need to irrigate so i did
analyze it in case there was any kind of
a carryover effect with the irrigation
but that was just simply the case this
year my three underlying cover crop or
three under vine cover treatments here
was the buckwheat which i talked about
the same glyphosate sprayed control but
what i did here was look at chicory
which is sort of a different growth
habit all the rest are pretty much
straight annuals chicory is a biannual
which often acts as a short-lived
perennial its first year you can see it
had that nice low-growing rosette form
established really nice
this year
even though i reseeded and there was a
complete cultivation operation obviously
some survived and it shot up all these
not only the low growing rosette form
but all those flowering stalks another
note thing to note about the chicory
that makes it sort of different is that
all the rest tend to be relatively
shallow rooted cover crops
chicory has this nice deep tap root and
these were taken very early in the
season
when i was doing soil sampling just a
few weeks ago i found chicory roots
going past even 20 centimeters in the
soil so it's just looking at a very
different growing habit of a plant
so first question did my cover where are
my cover crops there why look at this
question if they weren't so yes in short
at all three sites the cover crops
established 2011 at my first site i had
mowed once already so that's why they
have much lower values i think that's an
interesting note in case a grower was
ever worried about it going out of
control mowing does sufficiently
decrease a lot of the biomass present
in both other years you can see animal
rye grass and buckwheat established well
but with a fair amount of weeds
and that in all years at all the
both sites the control was essentially
vegetation free
you can see the biannual growth habit of
chicory reflected in the biomass with it
being relatively low in that first year
but a lot a lot of it was present this
last year and buckwheat was relatively
consistent
so one of my first measures of
vegetative growth was looking at cane
diameter this is a bit of a goldilocks
story when we go to prune in the winter
we don't want a cane that's too thick or
too thin
and the rough
ideal that some people argue is about
pencil thickness or six millimeters
on my first site there were never any
significant differences made um on cane
diameter but on my second site in this
last year chicory actually did
significantly reduce the cane diameter
down to six millimeters from just around
seven compared to the glyphosate control
so it might not be a big difference but
it definitely was a lower value that's
closer to what we would consider more
ideal
as i said i tracked shoot lengths and
could subsequently calculate shoot
growth rates throughout the season for
my first sight there was never an effect
in 2012 but this last year natural
vegetation actually did have a greater
shoot growth rate in the early july time
period and at my second site there was
never any significant effect on shoot
growth rate by the under vine cover crop
treatments
so this is this epqa i was talking about
earlier
at site at the first site the annual
ryegrass the buckwheat and the natural
vegetation never affected any of the
canopy characteristics uh same goes from
the first year at site number two
however in this last year chicory did
significantly affect canopy
characteristics it reduced the total
number of leaf layers in the canopy
it reduced the occlusion layer number
which means the number of shade
producing layers in the canopy and then
not surprisingly if you have fewer shade
producing layers and fewer leaves it
actually increased the cluster exposure
flux availability which is a big phrase
for the light exposure on clusters
this graph here as you move left to
right on the x-axis you're moving from
deeply shaded fruit to highly exposed
fruit so in our world we tend to want
more exposed fruit for disease
management purposes
you can see that the
tall blue bar and the yellow bars are
the control treatments and they by far
and large were dominated by deeply
shaded fruit whereas when you come and
look over here at the more exposed
regions it was the two trickery
treatments that had much more exposed
fruit and the buckwheat was yet again
intermediate
uh we take pre we pro when we prune in
the winter we'll calculate all that
growth um from the last season
and way um in the first site there was
no significant difference among pruning
treatments in 2011 and 2012 2013 data
will be coming
but i don't have it for you yet
and then at my second site what's
interesting here is that there was
actually a significant cover crop by
irrigation interaction effect
where the irrigated control yielded a
significantly higher pruning weight than
the non-irrigated buckwheat but that's
the only definitive relation that really
came out in that
so pre-dawn water potential which at
this point i think almost everyone in
this room has heard me complain about
is when
i go out to the vineyard at 3 30 in the
morning because there is no
transpiration on the plants and this is
when the vine water status will have
equilibrated the soil moisture
and so i'm getting a rough measure on
soil moisture where the rooting zone
grape roots are
in 2012 there were no differences in
2013 there was one significant
difference at my first sight
it actually did happen
the control was
significantly slightly less water
stressed
the more negative the value the more
water stress but i would just like to
point that negative
one and a quarter bars to negative half
a bar is hardly what we would call water
stressed as i said minus eight was the
limit that we began to see an inhibition
of vegetative growth so these are just
essentially very well hydrated vines
uh same goes for site number two there
were never any significant differences
in this predawn water potential
so going from the least amount of stress
to the most amount of stress of vine is
seeing midday stem water potentials are
taken at solar noon and kind of looking
at the maximum potential water stress
for site number one there was never any
significant differences in the midday
stem water potential among the cover
crop treatments
for site number two there was never any
significant difference in the midday
stem water potentials among treatment
those black arrows indicate when
irrigation was initiated in 2012 and as
you can see by the graph uh 2013 was
just a much wetter year we just never
received those that level of water
stress those vines were very well
hydrated
even with the presence of an under vine
cover crop
so to look at see if there's a potential
nutrient effect of having these
underlying cover crops right there in
the rooting zone of the vine
we took petial tissue at verizon sampled
and submitted for analysis uh 2013 data
is still pending but uh this is the data
from 2012.
the overall story here is that there is
no overall story there was no consistent
effect that i could find interestingly
annual ryegrass actually increased the
levels of phosphorus compared to the
herbicide control and increased levels
of iron
at the second site there was there was
no effect on any of the nutrients except
for nitrogen and you can see yet again
there was this interaction effect where
the irrigated control had significantly
more nitrogen than both the buckwheat
treatments
so at harvest we look at different
measures of yield i look at the total
number of clusters per vine so a lot of
counting
and then we weigh these total clusters
on a pervine base basis to get a yield
per vine you can then calculate an
average weight per individual cluster
and then from that from those clusters i
take individual berries and weigh them
out so i can get an average weight per
berry and then from that you can
calculate on average how many berries
there were per cluster
so for my site number one there was
never a terribly consistent effect
except for that annual rye grass
did influence the number of berries per
cluster having significantly fewer
same with the cluster weight was
slightly smaller but significantly so
then actually the buckwheat treatment
and the buckwheat treatment
but no terribly consistent effect i'll
take a moment here to explain what the
rivas index is too that's a very common
measure in the grape and wine community
to help evaluate the ratio of
reproductive to vegetative growth what
we do is on a pervine basis take the
total yield and fruit like how much that
fruit weight in kilograms divided by the
pruning weight we harvest that
subsequent winter from the vine and
kilograms so essentially ends up as
kilograms or kilograms or a unitless
ratio and what exactly the ideal ratio
is that's a wonderfully debated subject
roughly ten some people say anywhere
between four to ten some people say ten
to twelve but you can see here there was
no significant effect on this ratio at
this
site so that's arg is annual
correct
annual ryegrass buckwheat control for
the glyphosate and nat nat short for
natural vegetation
so you're seeing it
so yeah i did see fewer berries per
cluster and in one year i saw a reduced
cluster weight
for site number two in 2012 there were
no differences in any of these
components but in 23
chicory head did have a pretty
consistent effect so while the total
number of clusters per vine was not
affected the yield per fine was
significantly reduced with chicory
present under the vines so if you do
that math it's not too surprising to
figure out that the cluster weight the
individual clusters weighed less when
the chicory was present
subsequently also the berries were
smaller for the chicory treatment and
the total number of berries per cluster
were smaller and i will get back to you
on if there was any difference in 2012
for the rivas index but there wasn't for
2012.
so uh this fruit is then crushed into
juice and analyzed
for site number one
the annual rye grass buckwheat and
natural vegetation compared to the
glyphosate spray control had no
significant differences on the bricks so
the sugar content our tatratable acidity
the ph or the yeast dissimible nitrogen
of the juice
for site number two
for 2012
what was interesting is at the beginning
of the season the buckwheat actually had
a significantly lower acid level
a lower titratable acidity than the
glyphosate control but by the end of the
season at harvest it was actually the
chicory that was had a significantly
reduced titratable acidity by just under
one gram per liter
there was never any cover crop effect
for on the sugar the ph or the yan
so the wine aroma sensory as i said once
you do all this grouping data you get a
visual representation of how people
found the wines to be similar by roma so
the closer two points are together on
these graphs indicate
the more similar by aroma they were
found to be
in 2012 you can see that while buckwheat
and natural
vegetation were found to yield more
similarly
aromatic wines they were all all the
undervine treatments were found to be
different by aroma than control and in
2012 that same trend kind of continued
with the buckwheat and natural being
found to be pretty damn different than
the control by
aroma so for my second site um here i'll
note that actually at the previous site
there were eight wines presented to
panelists like i said duplicate lots of
wines there were four treatments so
eight wines were presented for this site
there were 12 wines presented because i
have six treatments buckwheat buckwheat
irrigated and non-irrigated chicory
irrigated and non-irrigated and my
control irrigated and non-irrigated
um 53 panelists participated so thank
you and then you were asked to sort them
between one and six groups
i don't know if i could have created a
more equidistant point graph than what
the numbers gave me
um
but that was what happened there's
potentially a trend here with uh the
control and buckwheat non-irrigated at
the bottom being kind of similar in a
group typically you want to analyze
these graphs by groupings but it's a
little rough here and similarly the
control irrigated and chicory irrigated
potentially but overall what is
interesting to note is that these wines
were found to be different
aromatically and that the irrigation and
cover crops were the things that made
them different
so at the end of the day
what can i say
it's important to note that these
underlying cover crops did yield
significantly different amounts of above
ground biomass this is important if
you're looking to
adopt this as part of your vineyard
floor management system understanding
that these cover crops are establishing
different depending on species
overall underlying cover crops did not
significantly impact measures of vine
vegetative growth the two exceptions
being that in this last year natural
vegetation essentially doubled the shoot
growth rate at one point in the season
and that chicory
in its second year of establishment
reduced cane diameter and the number of
leaf layers in the canopy which resulted
in greater cluster exposure to light
underlying cover crops were not found to
significantly affect pre-dawn or midday
stem water potentials and similarly
there was no consistent effect on the
petiole nutrient content taken at
verizon these points are important to
note because the whole premise of why
growers are spending a lot of money and
a lot of time to keep a vegetation free
zone under vines is they fear there will
be some kind of water or nutrient effect
on the vines which my work has at least
preliminarily shown and confirmed with
pass work that this just isn't the case
at least in this region
under vine cover crops on the whole were
not found to also impact harvest yield
this is important if a grower especially
a lot of growers here
are
not making tons of money their costs of
management are quite expensive for any
of the viniferas including riesling so
they cannot take a hit and yield
potentially so this is important to note
that for most of the species tested
there were no impacts the one big major
exception being that chicory in its
second year of establishment
significantly reduced vine
yield and cluster size by 25 percent
that the berries per cluster and berry
mass was reduced by 14 percent
um
i will interestingly note though that i
am not in the
viticulture is not the business of
optimizing yield we're in the business
of optimizing whatever the winemaker
perceives as the wine quality and
there is often a notion that too much
yield will have detriment to wine
quality so currently many vineyard
managers pay lots of money to have crews
go through and drop crop
so this reduced yield actually may not
be quite the deal breaker most people
are thinking of in our industry that
could actually be saving you a pass in
the vineyard with your crew
similarly
some people do prefer smaller berry size
so this reduced berry mass could be
beneficial if that's what you were
looking to achieve in your vineyard
overall undervine cover crops were not
impacting your juice composition with
the exception being that chicory at
harvest did reduce titratable acidity by
one gram per liter if you're happy with
your juice characteristics then hey it
looks like undervine cover crops
probably won't mess with that except for
maybe chicory um here too i would argue
that a one gram per liter reduction
could be beneficial i don't know if
anyone here has tasted our wonderful
finger lakes riesling but sometimes they
can be a little acidic
dropping this by one gram per liter
could
be desirable to certain wine makers
goals
for a few of my data measures including
the pruning weights and pedial nitrogen
there was a significant cover crop by
irrigation interaction
this is sort of interesting to note
because it's indicating that these
underlying cover crops could have
varying effect in different soil
moisture conditions
so understanding your specific site and
any variability in your site could be
really critical if you're looking to
adapt this to your vineyard floor
management plants
and the one consistent effect that we
saw year after year was that wine aroma
was impacted by the presence of
underlying cover crops in all years
why since i just talked about a lot of
how my data was not significantly
impacting measures of vine growth or
water status or nutrient content
i have a few theories on this so bear
with me
that epqa measurement i took
that evaluated the canopy characteristic
and light penetration the canopy i took
once at verizon similarly i took
nutrient status of the vine via petiole
tissue sampling once at verizon
it is known
from work out of our lab misha who just
graduated with a phd
from gavin sachs in food science he did
work with justine that showed the timing
of cluster light exposure can
dramatically affect concentrations of
tdn tdn is that very characteristic
petrol gasoline aroma that riesling is
sort of famous for
um so that not only did the
timing cluster light exposure impact
these important aroma precursors and
riesling but the overall cluster light
exposure uh jim meyer
myers from our lab just put out a paper
showing that very important aroma
precursors in the fruit that create a
lot of characteristic riesling aromas
are impacted by the quantity of cluster
light exposure so i only looked at this
diff at this potentially
different um
these differences in cluster lights
which are at one point the season at
verizon if there were differences
earlier in the season or later in the
season they could have had dramatic
effects on aroma precursors and i was
simply unable to detect them so my same
idea with nutritional differences
if there were a nutritional difference
early in the season or much later in the
season than verizon that was affecting
the biosynthesis of these aroma
precursors in the grapes
i wouldn't have been able to detect it
so those are sort of our biggest
theories especially when it comes to
cluster light exposure
but another thing not to rule out is
that green volatiles
could be impacting wine aroma i am
introducing a lot of vegetation directly
underneath the vine some very
preliminary work from justine and dr
gavin sachs has shown that hedging
materials directly under the vines can
impact
certain characteristics of wine so
kind of taking the next step further too
we also know that decomposing plant
tissues do give off green volatiles and
like i said i've introduced a lot of it
into the vineyard so there is that
potential interaction going on
so where do i go from here i've spent
three growing seasons studying this
well i've actually just received the
northeast uh sar
graduate student grant to continue my
work at my second field site the site at
lansing looking at if there's a
potential more long-term four-plus years
of effect of underlying cover crop
establishment
so i'm excited to be able to continue
that work there similarly since we do
know that these wine aromas were
perceived as very different when
underlying cover crops were present um
doing the more chemical side of things
looking at potential compounds that
could be responsible for these
differences further
preference testing so all i can tell you
from those graphs is that the wines were
different i can't tell you if that was a
good or bad thing so preference testing
would allow me to better analyze that
and understand potential consumer
reactions of being sold wine that was
grown without herbicide
similarly we're still sort of on the
search for the holy grail of cover crops
uh chicory's showing some promise but an
undervine cover crop that could come
that could compete on a level to
actually see this reduction in
vegetative growth would still continue
to be a goal um since we do still have
this excessively vegetative growth habit
in the finger lakes and lastly
understanding how your vineyard floor
management decisions including using
herbicide compared to an underlying
cover crop are affecting the iota of
your entire agro ecosystem could be
something that would be very interesting
these are works
cited we all in science stand on the
shoulders of the giants before us
um at this time there's so many people
i'd like to thank um i especially want
to thank eric and the cornell orchards
crew and john wagner out at wagner
vineyards for allowing a graduate
student to run amok in their vineyards
and making their life i know more
difficult but uh without their hard work
i wouldn't have been able to do any of
this work
i want to especially take a moment to
thank the cornell drearer committee
because i am the fortunate recipient of
the frederick drear award this year and
i'm basically counting the days till i
will be leaving for marlboro where i
will be going off to savion blanc
country for quite a while where of all
things i'll be doing some undervine
cover crop research
and i've also accepted um
a lab tech position with individual wine
company
to work the 2014 harvest over there but
never fear i'll be back
um i've just i've accepted uh continuing
on for my phd working here with justine
to stop or to continue on with some of
the work that um i've done here and
presented to you today to you for my
master's at this time i'd be happy to
take any questions and thank you
everyone for listening
uh definitely so the question was in
relation to the fact that uh the annual
rye grass treatment exhibited higher
levels of phosphorus and um iron and had
had certain yield effects
well yes it was it was not a predominant
effect the number of berries per cluster
was significant but not on a level that
would uh i would have been shot from the
rooftops
and it wasn't consistently it was only
the one year that we saw a reduction in
cluster size so
um
my sort of response is that yes we
certainly think the soil microbiota and
all that could be dramatically affecting
it the soil side of the undervine cover
crops is more the project of um it was
becky ciriani and adam carl in our lab
has taken over and looking a lot at that
and that's sort of it but definitely
it's something to consider i think
what's unique in this situation that
could be dramatically affecting the soil
biota is the fact that we have hilling
up so we're essentially doing a giant
mulching of these
decomposing or cover crops into the soil
every winter and then we're mixing it
all up again in the spring so i think
that's potentially where you're getting
some of these interesting effects and
how these plants are decomposing too
could have some dramatic effects so
certainly it's of something of interest
and yeah those results were a little
surprising and i'm still waiting to get
results back from our cornell nutrient
lab and when i get those i'll be able to
further see if this is a consistent
year-to-year effect
the questions about training of the
sensory individuals in short they
weren't so for this sort of study you do
not want trained individuals they are
given an explicit set of instructions
they are allowed to ask me questions and
i can
expound on the procedure but the idea is
that i am looking for
a just normal white wine consumer the
one limitation was that on average you
drink white wine about once a month i
was looking for wine drinkers not just
anybody but um we weren't this wasn't
what was what you might be thinking of
which is called a descriptive analysis
panel where you have explicit training
on the different characteristics um
you'll have training on what you think
the characteristics are in this type of
wine and then subsequently the standards
of lemon flavor or standards of
acid flavor and those sorts of things
this was sort of not supposed to be that
this is about your own perception of the
aroma i'm not looking to identify aromas
so however you perceive them to be
different you group them accordingly
so the question is is there a tendency
in difference testing to find more
differences that may exist that's always
the risk when you're asking someone to
find differences they can be prone to
that
this is a little more i would say
they are presented with the option of
putting them all in one group which
people did
if they found that there were no
differences so while it is always a
problem there's always a problem like
that i think with almost any sensory
test you do there's going to be some
bias that way so i think this test was
pretty representative of being able to
determine differences but like i said at
the end of the day all i can say is
differences i can't tell if they were
preferred or not or while relatively
they might have been different from each
other but if overall compared to all the
whites the world they weren't that
different i can't say that because i
didn't have any other externally tested
lines so there's a balance that way so i
haven't so the questions about
mycorrhizal biomass in where i'm having
these cover crops potentially a nutrient
effect um i have not looked at that in
any kind of scientific form for me to
actually say
there was a difference or anything um
doing quick research on these cover
crops there is that potential especially
like with chicory i definitely know just
doing my soil samples i saw them but um
and i'm still waiting to get some of the
back and research potentially back this
year about the chicory but
um in short i just don't know that's on
the soil side of things and that's
definitely a direction that would be
very interesting
what would i recommend to the grower i
would say if you're a grower who um
is looking to reduce their inputs which
i think every viticulturist should be
doing and i and if you are relatively
happy with your vineyard i think looking
at these annual underwine cover crops
especially something like buckwheat
which was pretty well controlled the
weeds were relatively low
it established very consistently year to
year and i just was not seeing effects i
would say why not try it why risk using
herbicide over and over destroying your
soil structure destroying your soil
health when you have another option
and then potentially something like
chicory which was showing those that
potential benefit beneficial reduction
in yield which is a weird phrase to say
but you know that's how our industry is
i would say why not try it um i think
there's a lot of perception that people
are really afraid of the cover crops
getting close to the fruiting zone and
um i definitely mowed at the first site
because it was a commercial vineyard but
i did not touch anything at the second
site i just let it go grow including
those flowering stalks of chicory and
while maybe management wise it wasn't
pretty and had offered a little few more
difficulties at the end of the day
though that was about as minimal
maintenance as i could and it was still
a pretty well established system so i
say to grow up what i would say from
growers is that it's unlikely you're
going to be seeing dramatic effects why
not try it and see what works for your
system
yeah the questions are growers ready to
change practices the world of
viticulture is notorious for it's like
the slowest rate of adoption curve ever
in terms of any agricultural field
we are based in history right rules and
how we grow things how we make our wine
that's you know literally
law on how you make your wine in europe
um
our growers ready to change i think some
are and there's always early adopters
who benefit from this kind of thing
there's definitely one grower in this
region who plants buckwheat not only as
an inter-row cover crop but just
everywhere under vines in a rows
everywhere he's willing to try it you
know you'll always have those people who
are
and i think it's stepping away a bit of
that perception of that very nice
looking vineyard of having vegetation
free
and stepping more into maybe more of the
agroman ecosystem management perspective
at the end of the day vineyards are also
places where people host weddings and
those sorts of things and it's always
hard for me to remove that when i'm at
the end of the day asking a grower to
make do something a little different
the chicory
yeah
good question um
i think even though the resulting vine
water status isn't being isn't that
different because these are own root or
not own rooted sorry but these are
vines that while grown with some
irrigation
i still think these roots are going
incredibly deep as we can see off in the
finger lakes and i think maybe while the
whole vine water status isn't being that
affected they are having to rely on
drawing water from those deeper roots
than the upper surface of the roots
where the
cover crop is actively growing and i
think there might be some of that just
physiological differences that are
causing some of that
similarly uh
it is known
that pre-verizon water deficits will
significantly impact fruit set that's
mark matthews work and um i think maybe
there were just some differences but
just so slight that statistically they
weren't there but um i yeah i don't
really have a great question or answer
to that unfortunately but i think it has
a lot to do with just the sensitivity of
my measurements
and maybe some physiological processes
going on in the vine that i'm not able
to detect
sure
i establish my cover crops by hand
seeding
and hand cultivating over them um it's
not that glorious but uh it was
efficient they sufficiently emerged
every year um we there is if this was to
be adopted on a larger scale we
understand most growers are not going to
be willing to walk over their acres and
acres of vineyards with hand seating but
uh there's interest and potential with a
few of our collaborators and the
extension side of things that have been
coming up with different ideas of how to
implement this on a vineyard level scale
but yeah i know that's right now is just
just just me myself and i have labor of
hand seating
yeah so the questions about the site to
site differences which there certainly
was
definitely i think there were
differences by the nature of the age of
the vines as i said that first sight was
almost 20 year old vines and the second
site here these vines are younger and um
i think it's just a little less fertile
a little less fertile a little less deep
soil of a site um what is interesting to
know though the one
carryover cover crop of buckwheat pretty
much had no significant effects at
either side so that's sort of my take
home message there's going to be more
and less vigorous sites here in the
finger lakes we have vineyards planted
on the whole range of them here so at
the end of the day i was trying to look
at more the state good step back from
what i can say at this particular site
and what could i say about the general
trend of using underlying cover crops as
a whole but yeah there's certainly were
site differences
and that's something to consider for any
grower you know
if they were looking to change up their
vineyard floor management is how their
site may differ but both these sites
were relatively fertile and both sites
were exhibiting excessive vegetative
growth
so that's why they were selected
any more questions
well thank you all for coming please
help yourself to any food remaining and
i'm up here if you want any further
questions
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu